m
le grand jour est arrivé pour la troupe
du petit émir de monter sur la scène du
théâtre de champ fleuri
fruit d'une année 2002 création et de
travail ce spectacle présenté par une
troupe de comédiens en situation de
handicap
un seul objectif montrer avec lumières
et poésie que les gens normaux n'ont
rien d'exceptionnel
le projet né il ya un an et demi on
s'est rencontré avec latvala fait à pire
sam beaucoup d'associations la déside
été voté ce projet qui à la fois un
projet télévisuel puisque quelques
émissions que tu es tourner sur ce
projet et surtout un projet documentaire
puisqu'on est en préparation d'un film
documentaire à 52 minutes sur le comment
vivre le handicap d'une manière
talentueuse on a gagné du temps de vie
parce que la notion de courage et de
poésie qui me revenait à les formidables
à l'importance est essentiel de mettre
en place des projets comme cela pourquoi
parce que vous avez peut-être dû voir le
film et quelques années qui s'appelle
des gens normaux n'ont rien
d'exceptionnel c'est un film qui montre
justement que dans la différence on peut
tout à fait normal et que dans la
normalité on peut tout à fait différent
tous des humains on est sur terre et ce
qui est important c'est de voir que quel
que soit le handicap et des gens qui
sont malvoyants les avions qui sont mal
entendants mais des gens qui ont des
difficultés à se mouvoir ou des
problèmes moteur et quel que soit le
handicap le point commun c'est la
sensibilité et la capacité à émouvoir
apporter des émotions et à intérioriser
aussi des émotions
au diable les différences vive le talent
librement inspiré du petit prince de
saint-exupéry le petit émir nous conte
l'histoire d'une rencontre entre un
homme en
tout se passe à l'époque actuelle dans
le désert juste au dessus de l'afrique
noire
un homme fait le paris dakar en 4 4 et
tombe en panne au milieu des dunes de
sable apparaît le petit émir et un stère
yeux et insaisissable l'homme dans sa
dynamique de performance et de réussite
seul en plein désert père d'un coup tous
ses repères il va progressivement se
laisser embarquer dans un voyage
initiatique qui remettraient en question
toute son existence émirats durant une
minute chaque semaine la troupe s'est
réuni pour mettre en place et répéter le
spectacle un rythme très soutenu
véritable organisation où il a fallu
prendre en compte les difficultés de
chacun
ça a été compliqué pour la musique pour
la langue des signes pour rené paul qui
est aveugle
donc on a pris à bras le corps toutes
ces difficultés pour en faire une
énergie très positive et les accompagner
dans la création pour arriver
aujourd'hui à présenter un spectacle de
qualité
malgré le stress et l'appréhension les
jeunes acteurs de la troupe ont assuré
sur scène une représentation de titres
sont très fiers et qui leur a apporté
une réelle confiance en eux c'était bien
et c'était c'était j'ai bien j'ai bien
j'ai bien assuré
et c'est et on est les t3 guinée si avec
tout le stress et avait un peu tout mais
j'assume tout en assurer ça m'a apporté
de la confiance en moi et du bonheur jeu
vivant mois et la joie et sur celle ci
qu'ils ont ils ont entre le 10 mai
agrégeait ils ont vu que j'étais aveugle
mais bon ils ont applaudi quand même
mais c'était super ben moi j'ai je
trouve que ça m'a fait plaisir mais en
fait vous pensez du théâtre et a fait le
travail travail et elle était très
fatiguée voulait abandonner mais elle a
continué elle pense que plus tard elle
aimerait encore continuer à faire du
théâtre
sur d'autres sujets
enfin